Wir wollen sprechen über den europäischen Top-Fußball. Heute blicken wir auf die Ligue 1 mit Jakob Haffke, auf die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, auf die La Liga– das war jetzt grammatikalisch falsch– mit Alex Truica und auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich begrüße hier meine Viererrunde bei mir. Guten Morgen, die Herren.
Er war beknickt. Er hatte einen Spitzennamen. Das reicht schon, dass deutsche Medien einfach davon überzeugt sind, dass er super ankommt, weil er schon einen Spitzennamen gekriegt hat.
Bis heute übrigens. Ich habe es jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende einmal kurz thematisiert. Genau das in einem Spiel für Newcastle. Dann sind wenigstens zwei, drei Medien mit aufgesprungen. Gestern habe ich noch einmal thematisiert, dass sich in England– also das entwickelt sich langsam zu Hass gegen Woltemade. Das ist halt einfach insofern logisch, weil er der Rekordtransfer ist. Und halt seit, ich glaube, in den letzten 15 Spielen nur einmal getroffen hat. Das war ein Doppelpack gegen Chelsea. Vielleicht sind sogar 16 Spiele inzwischen. Kann sein, dass ich es mixe. Auf jeden Fall schon lange nicht mehr. Und die spielerischen Leistungen sind halt gar nicht.
Der deutsche All war das.
Genau, ganz genau. Und jetzt wird es richtig hässlich. Ein ehemaliger Club-Boss hat den richtig zu saugemacht. Und jetzt geht es los in England. Und der ist weder so überragend gewesen, noch war wir zu mies. Und es ist auch jetzt nicht alles so mies bei Woltemade. Sondern der hatte einfach eine wahnsinnig effiziente Phase zu Beginn der Saison, wo halt alles reingefallen ist, was ihm irgendwie vor den Kopf oder vor den Fuß gekommen ist. Also er hatte eine Chancenverwertung wirklich von über 50 Prozent. Also es war erstaunlich. Und ja, den haben sie nicht ersetzen können. Sie haben aber– und das ist der größere Punkt– sie haben nie gelernt, für ihn zu spielen. Und er macht weiterhin das, was er macht. Er fällt halt wahnsinnig viel ins Mittelfeld. Hat jetzt auch gestern zum Beispiel nicht im Sturmzentrum begonnen. Das ist ja grundsätzlich mal ganz nett. Aber dann brauche ich halt ein Workaround. Und ich dachte, dass man in Langa deshalb holt, damit man sozusagen Tempo um ihn herum hat, damit er fallen kann, das Pressing anziehen kann. Mit Vissar hätte man theoretisch jemanden, mit dem man gegengläusige Bewegungen hätte einstudieren können. Nur ist Vissar erst gar nicht da gewesen, weil er verletzt war. Dann ist er so langsam im Dezember zurückgekommen, aber wirklich nur langsam. Hat dann dreimal getroffen. Generell war so Jahreswende. Da hatten sie immer vier Siege in Folge. Das war okay, aber auch nur okay. Jetzt ist es schon wieder nichts mehr. Jeder Sieg, den sie holen, ist wahnsinnig mühsam, ist alles dramatisch. Das ist dann der finale Punkt, um es einmal rund zu machen. Ohne Bruno Gimaraes– das ist wie gehabt, also hat sich in den letzten drei Jahren gar nichts verändert– sind die einfach eine Klasse schlechter. Die brauchen den im Aufbau oder in der zweiten Phase. Egal, aber sie brauchen ihn jedenfalls. Sandro Tonali hat auch so eine Mini-Krise gehabt. Wobei, die war gar nicht so mini, wenn ich mir für seine Verhältnisse ernsthaft überlege. Es ist keine gute Saison, es wird gerade ein bisschen besser, weil er scheint etwas fleißiger gegen den Ball wiederzuwerden. Das hilft schon mal ein bisschen, aber die absolut genialen Momente sind nicht da. Dazu kam ja jetzt noch, dass seine Repräsentanz, den am Deadline Day total desperat angeboten hat bei Arsenal, obwohl die den gar nicht zahlen können und Newcastle nichts davon wusste. Also es ist auch so atmosphärisch nicht ganz so clever gelöst, auch wenn ich es gerne gesehen hätte, muss ich sagen. Also das fände ich schon nicht unspannend, den bei Arsenal zu haben, aber es ist natürlich ein bisschen ungut, wenn das so läuft. Und jetzt wird halt diskutiert. In England hat Eddie Hau vielleicht sogar zu viel Macht auf dem Transfermarkt. Die haben ja komplett einmal ihre gesamte Administration verändert. Also die hatten zwischenzeitlich gar keine, weder einen Geschäftsführer, noch einen Sportdirektor. Das ist jetzt alles aufgefüllt mit, wie ich finde, auch guten Leuten. Zumindest ist das im Moment so die Einschätzung dessen, aber wieder nichts getan. Da gab es ja noch, wenn du dich erinnerst, Osula und Frankfurt-Gerüchte. Die sind auch wahr. Also Frankfurt hat sich für den interessiert. Es war nur so, dass Newcastle halt wusste, sie können sich, selbst wenn sie ihn verkaufen, ist da einfach nur ein weiterer Körper weg. Und sie können ihn nicht ansatzweise ersetzen. Also in der Premier League bedeutet ja Ersatz für egal, welchen Stürmer, also irgendein Teil des Kaders, 10 bis 15 Millionen. Und sie hätten von Frankfurt nicht mal im Ansatz das zurückbekommen. Und das klickt ja dann auch erst in den Bilanzen etwas später rein, sodass sie nichts hätten tun können. Also haben sie sich entschieden, das nicht zu machen. Komischerweise, in der Abwehr haben sie sich anders entschieden. Da haben sie Jamal Esselsoh abgegeben, der natürlich 0,0 Rolle gespielt hat. Das ist auch so eine Eigenart von Eddie Howe, dass er dann im Ende auch nur mit 13, 14 Leuten geht. Aber man merkt denen halt, diese ganzen Spiele zu leisten haben, brutal an, wie müde sie sind. Also keine Frische, das ist wahrscheinlich das richtige Wort. Nicht müde, sondern keine Frische.
Ganz kurz, Tonale, weil Tonale ist echt spannend. Ich finde auch, der ist total müde. Das sieht man denen an. Du sagst es ja, die haben ja nicht nur die vielen Premier League und Cup-Spiele, die haben ja auch nur die Champions League. Wenn du da mit 13, 14 Mann gehst, mit der Intensität, das sieht man Tonale an. Also Tonale ist wirklich spannend. Diese Nummer am Ende mit Arsenal habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden. Ich sage nur Richtung Sommer. Juve wird sehr viel probieren bei Tonale. Also Juve hat ihn jetzt so ein bisschen auserkurren. Das wäre der eine riesen Transfer, den sie probieren. Keine Ahnung, logisch, wie seine Gedanken das sind. Vielleicht will er auch in der Premier League bleiben. Aber Tonale wird spannend werden.
Also mein Tipp ist, es hängt extrem mit dem Auskommen zusammen. Max hat ja vorher gesagt, es reißt langsam ab. Es ist aber immer noch alles okay. Wir vermuten ja, dass Platz 5 reichen würde für die Champions League-Qualifikation. Minus 7, glaube ich, sind es, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Das ist machbar. Zumal die anderen ja auch kein Stück stabil sind, die da runter rumschwirren. Das ist schon machbar, aber ich kann mir schwer vorstellen, dass der... Das ist ja immer das Problem. Die machen ja seit Jahren das Gleiche. Die haben dann so einzelne europäische Nächte, wo du denkst, yes, jetzt habe ich die Wahrheit gesehen. Paris Umstellung auf Fünferkette war echt gut. Gestern haben sie auf Fünferkette gespielt. Ich habe selten was Schlechteres gesehen. Also ohne Witz, das war für ihre Verhältnisse, die stellen ja in der Theorie, den sage ich immer, und ich bin da auch fest davon überzeugt, den besten mittleren Block des Landes. Weil das ist ja körperlich... Das gehört ja verboten, was die da rumstehen haben. Und wenn die das ordentlich mit Intensität füllen, dieses Eddie-Hausche-System da, dann ist das halt super schwierig zu knacken. Also gestern, das war Wahnsinn, wie die sich haben auskontrollen lassen. Das hat er dann auch umgestellt zur Pause, hat aber nur nichts mehr gebracht, aber das hängt vermutlich mit der Müdigkeit zusammen. Mentaler Art, wie auch immer, I don't know, aber es gibt sie, diese Leistungen. Die gibt es in jeder Champions-League-Saison 2, 3, wo du denkst, ja, das ist es. Und die gibt es auch in der Premier League manchmal, diese Leistungen. Und dann kommt aber wieder so ein Geschlampe mit dazu, dass sie halt einfach in dieser Saison, jetzt gerade in der Phase, auch wieder extrem haben. Also für ihre Verhältnisse extrem. Vergangenes Saison war es oft so, dass sie teilweise die Ergebnisse geholt haben. Leistungen waren nicht so gut. Jetzt war es in der Saison eine Zeit lang so, dass die Leistungen eigentlich okay waren. Zunächst die Ergebnisse nur nicht. Und jetzt ist leistungstechnisch auch alles weg. Und dann wird es auch hässlich, glaube ich, da. Also das wird jetzt dann langsam, wenn es so weitergeht, noch zwei, drei Spiele. Und dann wird es ungut.
Und dann kommt zu diesem eh schon sehr müden Kader noch das Auslösungsglück, dass man nach Karabak darf. Und zwischendurch dann nochmal auswärts bei City spielen, gegen die man ja jetzt eben gerade dieses 1 zu 3 hatte im Pokal. Also ja, das wird echt nochmal interessant bei Newcastle. Jetzt waren wir doch ein bisschen länger hier noch im Thema drin. Aber gab ja auch wirklich viel zu erzählen. Jakob, was gibt es denn noch aus der Ligue 1 zu erzählen?
Ja, da habe ich mal was Positives noch mitgebracht. Und zwar eine echte Underdog-Story eines Aufsteigers. In der letzten Folge hatten wir über Paris FC gesprochen, bei denen das ja überhaupt nicht zutrifft. Und jetzt haben wir aber mit dem FC Lorient ja zumindest eine deutlich eher eine Underdog-Story. Denn die haben jetzt auch im Sommer nicht viel ausgegeben, haben, glaube ich, gut zwei Millionen an neuen Transfers investiert. Und das sah auch erst zu Saisonstart so aus, als würden sie sich ganz schön schwer tun. Sie haben die ersten Punkte eigentlich nur geholt, wenn der Gegner in Unterzahl war. Das war so ein Lauf, der ganz faszinierend war. Sie haben das erste Mal gewonnen in Gleichzahl ein Spiel am 30.11. damals gegen Nizza. Also hat dann wirklich relativ lange gedauert. Da war unter anderem auch dieses Freak-Spiel dabei. Da hatten wir, glaube ich, auch mal darüber geredet, wo es da drinnen in den ersten 20 Minuten schon zwei rote Karten gekriegt hatte und Lurion das dann ausgenutzt hat. Man muss sagen, dahingehend haben sie dann ihre Chancen auch super genutzt, dass sie aus diesen Überzahlen immer echt viel auch gemacht haben. Und jetzt sind sie aber tatsächlich seit dem 2. November auch ungeschlagen, und zwar in allen Wettbewerben. Also auch im Pokal haben sie gestern gegen Paris FC gewonnen, stehen da jetzt im Viertelfinale. Damals haben sie gegen Lens 0 zu 3 verloren in der Liga. Und das führt jetzt dazu, dass man sie eigentlich so als klaren Abstiegskandidaten schon auf den Schirm hatte. Jetzt stehen sie aber auf Platz 9, haben 14 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 16. Und bei dem Tempo, was die unteren drei, Nond, Oxair und Mess vorlegen, kann man nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass es da nochmal eng werden dürfte. Zumal, also die Form spricht natürlich für Lorient. Aber selbst wenn sie jetzt nur noch fünf Punkte holen oder so in den letzten 14 Spielen, sollte das schon reichen. Also kann man, glaube ich, davon ausgehen, dass sie den Klassen halt definitiv jetzt eingetütet haben. Gut, es gibt immer wieder besondere Geschichten. Ich glaubte aber nicht dran. Und momentan haben sie sogar auch nur, je nachdem, worauf es letztendlich hinausläuft, welche Plätze für Europa reichen, nur zwei bis drei Punkte Rückstand auf die europäischen Plätze. Das wiederum ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu hoch gegriffen. Das kann ich mir nicht unbedingt vorstellen, dass das jetzt so anhalten wird, denn sie haben auch so einen kleinen Lauf. Da steht zum Beispiel auch Mittelstürmer Bamba Dieng ziemlich sinnbildlich für, der jetzt in den letzten vier Spielen drei Tore gemacht hat, dann im Pokal auch noch fünf Mal getroffen hat, in den letzten drei Pokalspielen. Also da jetzt wirklich plötzlich acht Tore in den letzten Wochen geschossen hat, nachdem er vorher gar keine Rolle gespielt hat. In der letzten Saison war er auch an Angé verliehen, hat da also auch schon League 1 gespielt, als Lorient hochgekommen ist. Und der kam jetzt so ein bisschen wie Phoenix aus der Asche, hatte in den letzten Jahren auch immer Verletzungsprobleme, ist jetzt so ein bisschen der Mann der Stunde bei dem Team. Und man muss auch dazu sagen, dass sie im Sommer in der Offensive ihren zentralen Spieler verloren haben mit Eli Junior-Cruppi, der ja jetzt auch bei Bournemouth durchaus performt in der Premier League, war letzte Saison in der Ligue 2 mit 22 Toren der Torschützenkönig, war allerdings schon nur noch ausgeliehen von Bournemouth, denn das ist dann wieder der Punkt, weswegen ich auch in der Einleitung ganz kurz gestockt habe, denn auch Lorient ist Teil eines Vulti-Club-Ownerships. Sie gehören zur Black Knight Group mit Bournemouth zusammen und dementsprechend hatten sie dann Gruppi, der ist eigentlich, ja, kommt schon von Lorient. Also es war nicht so, dass sie den von Bournemouth ausgeliehen hatten, aber der ist dann halt letztes Frühjahr von Bournemouth auch offiziell gekauft worden für 13 Millionen und durfte dann aber bis zum Sommer noch bleiben, sie also in die erste Liga schießen. Aber dafür, jetzt fernab der ganzen Diskussionen darum, die wir ja hier auch immer wieder gerne führen, finde ich schon bemerkenswert, dass sie halt nicht, also es ist nicht so wie bei Straßburg, dass jetzt die Black Knight Football Group sagt, okay, wir geben euch jetzt tonnenweise Geld. Ich hatte es ja gerade gesagt, sie haben 2 Millionen ausgegeben im Sommer. Und dann auch Groupie eigentlich nicht wirklich ersetzt, sondern das halt viel von innen heraus gemacht, mit Spielern aus der eigenen Jugend durchaus. Also zum Beispiel im Sturm dann Sambu Sumano, der bevor die Jäger jetzt so explodiert ist, auch eine gewisse Rolle gespielt hat. Dann auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert Pablo Pagis, ein 23-Jähriger, auch aus der eigenen Jugend. Der hat jetzt auch schon 6 Tore gemacht, ist damit in der Liga Lurians bester Spieler. Es ist so ein offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, Außenspieler, der auch einen echt guten Schuss hat. Also den finde ich echt bemerkenswert. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Name, auf den man mal ein Auge haben kann. Ist auch beidfüßig, finde ich ein sehr interessanter Spieler. Dann haben sie auf der linken Schiene, also sie spielen immer so ein 3-4-3. Da ist mit Arsène Kouassi ein ivorischer linker Verteidiger, der jetzt gegen Nantes am letzten Spieltag, auch in der Schlussphase ein schönes Freistoß-Tor geschossen hat. Den haben sie im Sommer für eine 1 Million aus der zweiten Liga von Ajaxio geholt. Der könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der im Sommer jetzt auch für eine zweistellige Summe schon wieder weggeht. Ist erst 21, zeigt da aber richtig gute Leistungen. Und so haben sie da echt ein paar interessante Spieler rund um Laurent Abagel. Das ist so das Urgestein und der Kapitän des Vereins im zentralen Mittelfeld. Eine der Säulen im Tor haben sie mit Yvonne Vogo, auch einen alten Bekannten, der ja bei Leipzig mal eine Zeit lang, zumindest unter Vertragsstand, hat da ja, glaube ich, nicht so viel gespielt. Aber der ist sozusagen vielleicht jetzt aus der Sicht, wenn man nicht so viel auf die Liga 1 guckt, so das Gesicht der auch relativ soliden Defensive. Also sie lassen, glaube ich, die siebt wenigsten Schüsse der Liga zu, stehen da also gut dabei, haben eine durchaus solide Abwehr. Also Olivier Pantaloni, der Coach, hat da echt was Gutes geformt. Da denkt man dann ja auch schnell dran, ob da jetzt vielleicht auf der Trainerbank, so der die nächste heiße Aktie sitzt. Das würde ich jetzt bei Olivier Pantaloni nicht unbedingt behaupten wollen. Der ist auch schon 59, was er jetzt auch auf dem Trainermarkt dann nicht unbedingt zumindest mehr das Talentalter ist. Der war auch ganz lange auf Corsica bei Ajaxio und war da Trainer und hat dann aber in der letzten Saison auch den Aufstieg schon zu verantworten gehabt bei Lurion, den sie ja auch vor dem finanzkräftigeren Paris FC geschafft haben. Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine der Positivgeschichten jetzt momentan. Und wenn es so weitergeht, auch definitiv der Saison in Frankreich.
Fantastisch, der FC Lurion. Vergessen wir mal das ganze Multi-Club-Ownership, weil du hast ja recht, es sieht nicht so viel aus.
Aber der Name ist wenigstens geil, Black Knight Football Group, da kann ich... Wenigstens das.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Ja, okay, gut, geben wir ihn, geben wir ihn. Gut, das ist der Blick.
Und ich habe noch einen Familienbezug, denn das haben wir auch gerne. Denn wir haben ja, glaube ich, irgendwann dieses Jahr auch schon über Regis Le Brice gesprochen und der Neffe von ihm spielt bei Lorient, Theo Le Brice.
Das wäre das Teil, was der Onkel kann, dann not bad.
Genau.
Okay, sehr gut. Das war der Blick nach Frankreich. Und dann blicken wir jetzt auf La Liga. Alex, was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, im Endeffekt zwei Themen, zwei kleine Themen, die Fabi Pakulac schon vor zwei Wochen hier im Rasenfunk besprochen hat. Aber die sind halt weiterhin aktuell bzw. mit so neun Turns. Das eine ist natürlich die Lage bei Real Madrid und die andere ist die persönliche Lage von Ters Degen. Ich weiß nicht, welche du als erstes besprechen willst.
Lass mal mit Ters Degen anfangen, weil das auch so die größeren Schlagzeilen hier gezogen hat. Und weil ich ja weiß, dass du da ja auch den Barca-Hintergrund hast. Wie wird denn das beim FC Barcelona aufgefasst, dass er jetzt schon wieder lange wegen einer Verletzung ausfällt? Muss man letztlich sagen, alles richtig gemacht aus Barca-Sicht jetzt?
Erstens, ja, wahrscheinlich das. Das klingt sehr makaber, aber schwere Muskelverletzungen, also Rupatur, die muss er operativ jetzt entfernen lassen oder muss sich operieren lassen. Er hat übrigens während wir hier recorden, glaube ich, auf Social Media einen Post publiziert, wo er sich an die Fans von Girona wendet und sagte, er entscheidet sich für die OP und fällt damit monatelang aus. Also, sagt er selber. Also, die Rede ist von mindestens zwei Monaten oder voraussichtlich zwei Monaten, im Idealfall vielleicht auch bis zu drei Monaten. Und jetzt timetable-mäßig, wir haben jetzt Anfang Februar, im Sommer ist ein größeres Event, da wäre er gerne dabei. Auch deswegen ist er ja dahin gewechselt zu Girona. Und das ist jetzt erst recht mit großen Fragezeichen versehen. Also, für ihn persönlich natürlich fatal, ganz, ganz tragisch und schlimm. Dass es sich vor allem nicht nur irgendwie den Oberschenkel ein bisschen reißt, sondern drei Wochen, mein Gott. Sondern wirklich, wir reden von zwei Monaten plus, die er da ausfällt. Und ja, ganz persönlich sehr, sehr schlimm für ihn, finde ich. Für Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch nicht die optimal News, meiner Meinung nach, aus Barcelonersicht, um deine Frage zu beantworten. Ja, Retrospektiv im Sommer, alles richtig gemacht durch Joan Garcia's Kauf und durch den Abgang von Tastegen, also durch das Rausgeleiten aus dem Verein, so nenne ich es mal. Ja.
Es ist schon einfach, es ist schon, also das hat ja schon Marco Reus Dimensionen bei Tastegen. So ein bisschen anders, weil er halt lange hinter Manuel Neuer stand, aber es ist einfach bitter. Aber nehmt ihr das auch so wahr, dass bei euch in den Ligen so manches Thema ein bisschen mehr Temperatur hat, einfach weil es jetzt diese letzten Monate vor der WM sind. Also ich habe zum Beispiel gestern Werder Bremen Schwerpunkt aufgenommen, da ging es um Marco Friedl, der ein bisschen gestänkert hat gegen Horst Steffen. Und da hieß es dann auch nicht so unrecht, naja, der will halt zur WM und der kommt nur als Innenverteidiger zur WM. Da kann er nicht links Verteidiger spielen und deswegen hat er sich beschwert, dass er links Verteidiger spielen muss. Ist das bei euch Uli in den Ligen auch so, dass man so das Gefühl hat, okay, das heizt zu manchen Konflikten noch mal ein bisschen auf?
Ja, logisch. Auch bei den Transfers glaube ich ganz häufig genau um das Thema, dass Einzelne sich noch ins Schaufenster stellen wollten und dass die Fenster aufgehen, finde ich schon auch.
Ja, in Italien ähnlich hat man ja auch die Namen. Also Raspadore hat man gerade ganz klar. Füllkrug hat man ja auch, hat ja Marius letztes Mal darüber gesprochen. Ja, geht es jetzt glaube ich für viele drum, in den nächsten Monaten Eigenwerbung zu betreiben, um dann im Sommer auch Fußball spielen zu können auf einer großen Bühne. Ja, mal gucken, wie wir da noch darüber berichten. Jakob, Ligue 1 wahrscheinlich ähnliches Bild.
Ja, ein paar, die nicht gewechselt sind, deswegen ein paar, die gekommen sind in die Liga und deswegen um ein bisschen Spielpraxis zu sammeln, die sie sonst nirgendwo kriegen. Also, wird schon eine Rolle gespielt haben.
Ja, in Spanien betrifft das Max übrigens den Namen, den ich gerade gedroppt habe, also den Tastin Konkurrenten, Ex-Konkurrenten, Juan Garcia, spielt eine herausragende Saison und ist aber nicht mal unter dem Top 3 der spanischen Torhüter. Und das ist ja schon nicht nur ein Kuriosum oder falsch, kann man nennen, wie man möchte, aber beschäftigt tatsächlich die Medien stark. Also, da gab es wirklich sehr, sehr viele Berichte und Meinungen. Da gibt es ja Radiosender, die noch und nöchig ihre Sendung füllen müssen. Und da wurden wirklich viel– was heißt Stimmung– gemacht, will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber es ging viel in die Richtung. Schau mal, wie gut er ist. Und für Luis de la Fuente, der Nationaltorhüter, ist er nicht mal einer der drei besten. Weil da sind wir ja schon beim Thema, gerade bei den Torhütern, ist eine besondere Position. Da willst du auch deine klare Nummer eins, die willst du nicht enteiern, die willst du nicht hinterfragen. Und dann der zweite und dritte müssen ja eher Teamplayer sein und müssen ja gar nicht die Besten sein. Da müssen halt einfach nur gut im Kader funktionieren oder im Dressing-Room und das willst du, das Thema willst du dir ungern aufmachen, wenn du da eine gute Kombi hast. Aber das Thema wird aufgemacht, weil Joan Garcia so dermaßen stark ist und Unai Simón, die eigentlich klare Nummer eins, nicht so sonderlich stark ist. Also in Spanien ist das das Thema Nummer eins in den letzten Monaten tatsächlich, die Torhüterposition.
Ja, könnte man ja auch einfach ein bisschen Temperatur rausnehmen, indem man sagt, komm, wir boykottieren einfach alle. Ich ruf mal Bernd Neuendorf an. Vielleicht will er sich umentscheiden. Vielleicht ist jetzt doch die Zeit, darüber zu reden. Aber vielleicht reden wir da mal in einer anderen Sendung drüber, ob es da Diskussionen auch in anderen Ländern gibt. Schauen wir mal auf Italien nochmal. Christian, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht? Ja, gerne. Reißen wir uns mal kurz an. Das ist dann sicher vielleicht auch mal ein Thema, für das nächste Mal tiefer reinzugehen. Aber Juve ist wieder auf Kurs und das hat sehr viel mit Lucianos Ballette zu tun, der ja eben im November übernommen hat. Und ja, der hat jetzt schon sehr schnell den Schlüssel da gefunden. Also Juve jetzt eigentlich seit Wochen, ja, in richtig guter Verfassung. Ich hatte es ja vorhin schon, für ganz vorne waren sie einfach zu weit weg. Es sind jetzt immer noch zehn Punkte auf Inter, weil Inter ja auch den großen Rhythmus fährt. Aber sie sind jetzt logisch wieder voll im Rennen um die Champions League. Sie sind auch an Napoli dran. Milan ist ja auch nicht so weit weg. Also, ich wollte es nur mal kurz anreißen. Schon beeindruckend, wie schnell Spalletti verstanden hat, was diese Mannschaft braucht und was er ihr geben kann. Vielleicht so zwei, drei kleine Appetitanreger. Also er ist auf Viererkette zurück, seit jetzt Bremer wieder da ist. Bremer haben wir öfter schon genannt. Juve mit Bremer ist halt eine andere Stabilität als ohne. Hatte davor wieder wochenlang verletzt gefehlt. Das kann man Igor Tudor logischerweise nicht anhängen, dass er ohne Bremer gespielt hat. Aber seit Bremer jetzt wieder da ist, ist er auf die Viererkette zurück. Jetzt so 4-2-3-1. Ganz klare Prinzipien. Turam und Locatelli bilden die Doppelsechse. Da hat er wirklich sehr gut gearbeitet, weil, wenn wir uns vielleicht ans Ballett erinnern, sowohl zu Napoli-Zeiten oder auch zu Inter, er hatte immer wirklich so einen klassischen Spielmacher, also Napoli-Lobotka. Bei Inter hat er Brosowicz, da hat er Brosowicz dazu gemacht, zu dem Taktgeber. Und jetzt weder Turam noch Locatelli sind so klassische Regisseure, deswegen den hat er einfach nicht. Und jetzt hat er so ein Workaround gefunden, dass er ohne klassischen Regisseur spielt. Also gerade im Spielaufbau geht viel über außen, jetzt auch über die Viererkette. Du hast Cambiaso, Calullo, die schieben gut an über außen, mit Yildiz und Concesau, die das auf außen unterstützen. Und jetzt haben Turam und Locatelli genau die Rollen bekommen, die sie wirklich am besten ausleben können, nämlich Locatelli ist so der defensive Anker. Der gibt wirklich Stabilität, macht sehr viel gegen den Ball, ja, gibt Balance. Und Turam hat ein paar Wetter weiter nach vorne geschoben, weil Turam halt einfach diese Atletik, diese Dynamik hat, auch mit Ball am Fuß da wirklich mal 20 Meter zu reißen, ist jetzt auch wieder torgefährlicher geworden. Also das nur so als kleines Beispiel dafür, dass Spalletti jetzt nicht plötzlich da fünf neue Leute bekommen hat, ist ja klar, konnte er gar nicht, sondern dass er einfach den Kader wunderbar gelesen hat und ja, also ist wirklich beeindruckend. Juwe ist total in Shape und ich bin jetzt auch gespannt in der Champions League. Also wenn es wirklich ins Achtelfinale gehen sollte, das ist schon anders Juwe als noch vor vier Wochen, sechs Wochen. Sie haben Selbstvertrauen, wie gesagt mit Bremer, hinten einfach wieder mit vier oder fünf mal wieder zu Null gespielt. Das beste Beispiel am Wochenende gewinnen sie locker 4-1 in Parma. Bremer ein Doppelpack, packt das sogar mal ein Doppelpack aus. Also jetzt nicht, dass er das müsste, aber Bremer gibt dir eine ganz andere Stabilität. Jonathan David hat wieder funktioniert, jetzt Halbwegs, den hat er auch ein bisschen in Shape bekommen, trifft jetzt häufiger, spielt gut für die Mannschaft. Yildiz war davor schon gut, ist weiter gut. Also ja, gutes Beispiel dafür, dass ein sehr guter Trainer, und ich glaube, Luciano Spalletti, klar können wir jetzt mal dieses Nationalmannschaftsabenteuer ein bisschen in den Klammer setzen. Das war logisch enttäuschend für beide Seiten. Aber was Spalletti, glaube ich, als Klubtrainer in den Jahren davor geleistet hat, sollten noch ein paar auf dem Schirm haben. Und das hat man jetzt halt eben einfach sofort gesehen, seine Intelligenz, auch seine Leadership. Also der Vertrag war erst mal nur bis Sommer sozusagen. Die werden logischerweise verlängern. Und letzte gute Nachricht noch kurz aktuell, bei Yildiz schaut es auch sehr gut aus. Da probieren sie logischerweise auch alles. Der hatte noch einen relativ kleinen Vertrag, sage ich mal. Da sind jetzt alle in Europa dran. Und da hat es jetzt wohl in der letzten Woche große Fortschritte gegeben. Also sind vielleicht nicht mehr weiter weg davon, ihn zu verlängern. Und dann wäre es Yildiz logischerweise auch das Sinnbild. Ja, das ist dann eine neue Juwe-Mannschaft, der ich. Kleiner Blick nach ganz vorne und dann hören wir auf mit Juwe heute. Ich glaube, dass Palette mit Juwe nächstes Jahr auch ganz oben in der Liga angreifen kann. Kenan Girdes ist auch eine der interessantesten Personalien überhaupt der letzten Jahre. Da würde ich so gerne nochmal mit ein paar Leuten beim F3 ansprechen. Ganz ehrlich, das ist einfach.
Aber gut.
So funktioniert es eben manchmal auch. Dann gehen wir nochmal ein letztes Mal durch die Ligen hindurch. Uli, wir schauen nochmal nach England. Wir schauen zu Brentford. Brentford steht auf Rang 7 und ist quasi das Anti-Brighton. Denn während Brighton 10 unentschieden hat, hat Brentford nur 3 unentschieden. Und steht damit immerhin für den Fakt, dass es entweder ein Sieg oder eine Niederlage gibt. Und das ist insofern bemerkenswert, weil die Premier League sich nämlich in einer 0 zu 0-Krise befindet. Man hat jetzt schon so viele 0 zu 0-Spiele gesammelt, wie in der gesamten vorherigen Saison. Was macht den Brentfordt besser als alle anderen Premier Leagueisten?
Sie spielen nicht unentschieden.
Sie verlieren auch mal, gell?
Genau. Wir spielen eine tolle Saison. Also eine, die ich nicht im Ansatz abkommen sehen. Weil nach Thomas Frank dachten wir, okay, da kommt jemand hin. Der ehemalige Standard-Coach war nie Chef-Trainer irgendwo gewesen. Das ist ja in der Premier League noch viel untypischer als irgendwo anders. Weil im Grunde gibt es gar keine Durchlässigkeit von der 2. in die 1. Liga. Keith Andrews ist ein sehr cleverer Kommunikator auch immer schon gewesen. Mitunter auch Experte gewesen. Super Typ. Und die ersten zwei, drei, vier, fünf Spiele der Saison dachte ich, um Gottes willen, die steigen ab. Das ist derart chaotisch gewesen. Und inzwischen ist das ein so super gecoachtes Team. Wie immer natürlich auch einen gewissen Standortvorteil, dass es vergleichsweise ruhig ist. Vor allen Dingen abgeglichen mit den anderen Teams in England. Aber haben mit Igor Thiago einen ganz, also wahrscheinlich den Zielspieler-Prototypen im Moment auf der Welt. Es ist ein physisches, absolutes Monster, aber weit mehr auch. Also Alvin Thonny, da spricht überhaupt gar niemand, jemals auch nur ansatzweise noch darüber. Und wenn ich sie so minimal vergleichen müsste, und das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum sie immer noch mehr gewinnen, als sie dann am Ende verlieren. Das ist ja ein unglaubliches Ergebnis an sich. Sie spielen nicht ganz so aggressiv, wie unter Thomas Frank. Sie sind schneller dabei, sich hinten reinzustellen und haben auch kein Problem, mal 20, 25, 30 Minuten gar nichts zu tun und einfach nur kompakt zu verteidigen. Das ist neu, weil da hatten sie immer Bienen im Hintern. Das tun zu müssen, da haben sie sich manchmal auch etwas naiv was gefangen in den letzten Jahren. Aber das ist ein bisschen besser geworden. Und für mich eine absolut positive Überraschung. Das ist vielleicht sogar die Positivste von allen, weil das habe ich niemals, also gerade nach den ersten Wochen, nie kommen sehen. Nie.
Und im Schatten von Igor Thiago mit dieser wahnsinnigen Bilanz von 16 Toren und einem Assist allein in den Liga spielen, Kevin Schade.
Und die Hälfte Elfmeter, da darf man auch nicht vergessen. Aber trotzdem.
Nimm mir die Freude doch nicht.
Alles gut.
Aber das macht ja dann die 6 Tore von Kevin Schade und die 3 Assists dahinter noch besser. Also der scheint da ja auch eine gute Rolle zu spielen und spielt ja auch immer.
Ja, der hat jetzt am Wochenende rot gesehen, etwas dümmlicher Platzverweis. Aber ansonsten ist der, also der hat nach wie vor das Problem, dass die Chancenverwertung durchaus besser sein dürfte. Aber die Läufe sind ein nicht ganz unwichtiges Element in dem Spiel, dass der da abseits Ballfern sozusagen ganz häufig in die Tiefe sprintet, sich weiterhin auch im Kopfball etwas verbessert und so. Also der spielt an sich eine richtig gute Saison, jahnt ja sowieso immer. Den kriegt man da ja nicht weg, der hat jetzt auch frisch verlängert. Das heißt, beide Deutschen, die da vollkommen unter dem Radar fliegen, werden, wir haben ja vorhin WM gehabt. Ich begrüße inzwischen jedes Mal, wenn ich Brentford mache, Julian Nagelsmann, weil ich fest davon ausgehe, der schaut zu.
Ja, ich finde es aber halt so interessant, weil, also das soll jetzt überhaupt gar kein Disrespect sein, aber bei Chris Führig reißen zwei gute Spiele nach Einwechslung, dass sofort wieder in Deutschland darüber diskutiert wird, muss er mit zur WM. Und Kevin Schade spielt die ganze Zeit bei dem Überraschungsteam der Premier League oder einem der Überraschungsteams der Premier League und wir reden da gar nicht drüber. Also es ist schon interessant.
Ich vermute, dass, also das ist ein bisschen dumm, was ich jetzt sage, aber nur ein bisschen hoffentlich. Ich vermute, dass es so einen ähnlichen Spielertypen in den Planungen Nagelsmanns gibt und deswegen ist vielleicht eine Doppelung da bei Schade und wenn die Chancenverwertung noch minimal besser werden würde oder generell die Effizienz der Output, dann könnte es den Spieler halt raushauen aus dem Kader.
Bitte auf zu weg posten, wer ist der andere Spieler?
Ja, da würde ich jetzt von jedem Tipp hören. Ich glaube, Lyra Zané ist quasi derjenige, der mehr oder weniger im… Entschuldigung. Nur so wie… Ich habe mich gar nicht mit jemandem unterhalten, der da nah dran ist und Nagelsmann setzt der Zané anders ein als der zum Beispiel auf Vereinsebene spielt in der Nationalmannschaft. Das heißt, der hat diese Rolle, also gar nicht mal ein Spielerprofiltypisch, sondern der hat diese, glaube ich, und das ist auch das, was der mir gesagt hat, der wird die Rolle haben, bei einem Turnier für eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten reinzukommen, Tempo zu machen, Gegenspieler zu binden und dead set. Mehr kann ja Schade eigentlich in der Nationalmannschaft realistisch nicht bekommen.
Das klingt aber nach El Mala, oder? Sein Profil. Super Joker mit Speed.
Ja, nur der hat einen 1 gegen 1.
Und El Mala spielt 40 Minuten in der Bundesliga und Kevin Schade spielt alle Minuten in der Premier League. Also wollte ich mich eigentlich auf den Arm nehmen. Der eine ist 24.
Nee, ist okay. Also, ich check es einfach nicht.
Ja, ich check, ich checke es einfach nicht. Also, nee, nee. Nein, ich verstehe es einfach nicht. Ich verstehe es wirklich nicht. Aber ich brauche mir auch nicht darüber diskutieren. Die Bundestrainer dürfen ihre eigenen Entscheidungen treffen. Aber ich darf dann kurz auch mein Unverständnis äußern.
Ich finde es auch schade.
Ohohohoho.
Also, ich lege mich... Ich lege mich aus dem Fest. Ich darf es nicht äußern, nee.
Er hat doch mal gesagt, er heißt Kevin Schade, oder?
Ja, das ist ja bis heute die größte Schade. Also da, ohne Witz, wenn ich den jemals treffe, ne? Was soll das denn? Ich wollte es den Engländern leichter machen. Am Arsch, ey. Der hat uns ein halbes Jahr gekostet, der Mensch.
Wie, warum denn das jetzt? Also, weil sie nennen ihn alle Kevin Schade und ihr müsst jetzt immer korrigieren, oder was?
Nee, es war so, dass der, ich, irgendwie waren da die 11 Freunde, meine ich, involviert, da gab es plötzlich eine riesengroße Story. Also es gibt immer, so muss man es vorher weg sagen, die Premier League ist ja sehr professionell und das meine ich wirklich ganz ernst in dem Fall. Es gibt vor jeder Saison, die werden auch geupdatet, immer Aussprachelisten, wo die Spieler sich selbst aussprechen. Wo sie halt sagen, my name is, was weiß ich. Und komischerweise, aber die Skandinavier sprechen sich immer alle Englisch aus. Also Thomas Frank. Und da habe ich mich mal gefragt, heißen sie Thomas Frank? Nö, Thomas Frank, aber okay, danke. Und da sagt dann in diesem Video, das hat dann irgendwann, glaube ich, Freunde haben es einfach mal entdeckt, die sind auch offen bei YouTube zugänglich, ich bin Kevin Schade. Und dann haben die ein Video gemacht und haben das dann, ich glaube, einen Artikel gemacht und haben das dann auch erklärt, warum das wegen Herkunft dies und das sein könnte, dass der halt Schade heißt. Dann haben wir natürlich alle gesagt, okay krass, Kevin Schade, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, was in meinen DMs los war, ne? Und irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später kommt dann aber doch wieder ein Interview, ja ne, ich wollte es eigentlich nur den Englern dann leichter machen, ich heiße natürlich Schade. Okay, cool, vielen Dank.
Diese Aussprachen gingen auch viral, ne? Gab es auf TikTok und Instagram, wie die sich die Spieler alle erinnern.
Es gab auch mal bei, ich weiß jetzt bis heute nicht, was richtig ist, Seat Kolasinak, haben wir die Bosniener gesagt immer, oder Kolasinac, und der hat in einem, da haben wir einem TheZone-Reporter meinen Auftrag gegeben, frag ihn mal. Und der hat ihn gefragt und er sagt in einem Video 3 verschiedene Aussprachen. Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, ist auch scheißegal.
Sorry, wollt auch gerade, ich glaub von Mois Ken gibt's auch, wo es sich mal Mois Ken nennt und dann heißt es sich Mois Keen.
Aber diese Highlights aus den Premier League Videos kann man sich gut mal angucken, da sind einige echt gold dabei. Also Nicholas Jackson ist auch richtig gut, Anja Farke ist super.
Die sind echt gut.
Ich sehe schon, dann muss ich mal gucken, ob ich den Link dazu finde und noch in die Show notes packe. Nicholas Jackson wurde ja von Christian Arbeit bei Union als Nicolas Jackson bei seiner Einwechslung bezeichnet. Und das ist natürlich näher wahrscheinlich an der richtigen Aussprache. Aber da ist mir erst mal aufgefallen, dass ich bei diesem Namen gar nicht drüber nachgedacht hab, dass ich den die ganze Zeit falsch ausspreche. Und wenn es einem ja auch bei anderen Namen die ganze Zeit um die Ohren gehauen wird, was da auch ehrlich gesagt allen egal hat, hat sich niemand gemeldet. Kommt aus der Premier League, der wird ja schon englisch ausgesprochen werden. Kevin Schade, stark. Jetzt will ich ihn noch mehr bei der WM mit dabei haben. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Wir blicken nochmal nach Frankreich, Jakob. Und da wolltest du nochmal kurz über ein paar interessante Wintertransfers sprechen.
Wen gibt es denn da so?
Genau. Ich habe zwei Unterthemen und ein Bonusthema. Und wir gehen von negativ zu positiv. Und negativ ist mir auf jeden Fall aufgefallen, dass Frankreich ja schon seit Jahren jetzt als Ausbildungsland gilt. Und es klar ist, okay, es werden wahnsinnig viele super junge Spieler schon früh reingeworfen, die dann auch wirklich riesiges Potenzial mitbringen. Und die gehen dann für viel Geld in andere Ligen. Jetzt nimmt es allerdings, finde ich, überhand, dass sie wirklich extrem früh wechseln. Und das hat man jetzt auch diesen Winter gesehen. Wir hatten es gerade bei Marseille schon mit Rubinho Vaz und Bacolar, die beide mit 18 jetzt schon weggegangen sind. Bei Monaco ist George Ilikena für 30 Millionen nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt. Der war auch lange noch kein Stammspieler, hat zwei Saison-Tore gemacht in dieser Saison. Natürlich ist es logisch, dass der Verein dann sagt, okay, machen wir, weil wenn der sich jetzt verletzt oder sich gar nicht durchsetzt in den nächsten Jahren, werden sie nicht 30 Millionen für den bekommen. 30 Millionen gab es auch für Stadtrännen, für Kada Meite, ziemlich ähnlicher Fall wie George Ilekena. Auch er hat erst fünf Tore im Profibereich gemacht in dieser Saison, gut 500 Minuten gespielt bei Stadtrännen. Trotzdem hat Al Hilal 30 Millionen auf den Tisch gelegt. Angé hat einen von den starken Stürmern, über die wir auch schon mal gesprochen hatten, in dieser Saison verkauft, an Fenerbahce. Also auch gar nicht so die typischen Ligen, in die die Spieler sonst gewechselt sind. Also nicht unbedingt England, Deutschland, sondern dann auch die Türkei und Saudi-Arabien. Auch da kriegt Angé im Gesamtpaket wohl so 30 Millionen. Das ist aber eine Laie mit Kaufpflicht. Und der krasseste Fall ist aber vielleicht beim FC Messe, die ja unten drin stehen und einen 17-jährigen Stürmer für 12 Millionen an Aston Villa verkauft haben, Brian Maddow, der 157 Minuten im Profibereich gespielt hat in seiner ganzen Karriere. Kein Tor gemacht hat in dieser Saison, fünf Mal als Joker gekommen ist. Und ja, der sollte eigentlich bei Metz jetzt in der Rückrunde, so wie ich das gehört habe, eine größere Rolle spielen, zumindest immer von der Bank kommen. Bei Aston Villa wird er sicherlich aber auch mehr Spielzeit sammeln können jetzt. Da bin ich ganz optimistisch.
Gut, er steht hier erstmal, dass er in die U21 von Aston Villa gewechselt ist, also aber dafür 12 Millionen Euro. Ist ja ehrlicherweise immer ein Anzeichen dafür, dass ein Markt dann überkauft ist, wenn eben so was passiert, muss man tatsächlich sagen.
Ja, aber ihm muss man fairerweise natürlich sagen, dass er Engländer ist, dementsprechend da dann auch dieser Homegrown-Faktor sicherlich auch noch eine Rolle gespielt hat zusätzlich dazu.
Klar.
Aber ja, es sind auf jeden Fall viele gegangen. Und dann der größte Transfer ist ja Jeremie Jacquet, der allerdings ja jetzt noch da bleiben wird bei Startrennen. Im Gesamtpaket glaube ich fast 70 Millionen. Das ist schon ein echt talentierter Innenverteidiger und der bringt auch alles mit. Aber ja, er spielt halt auch nur bei Startrennen und die sind jetzt auch nicht die absoluten Überflieger. Es ist schon viel Geld.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, vor allen Dingen aus Liverpools Sicht. Also klar, das ist auch wieder nur ein Bilanzthema, aber die haben genau zwei gesunde Innenverteidiger und keinen gesunden Rechtsverteidiger. Und jetzt holen sie jemanden für den Sommer. Im letzten Sommer haben sie 60 Millionen.
Ich dachte auch, ich gucke nicht richtig.
Das macht keinen Sinn. Im letzten Sommer bieten sie 60 Millionen für Marc Gay, aber nicht 20 Millionen im Winter. I don't get it. Also wenn es dein Wunschspieler ist. Also klar, das hängt hundertprozentig auch mit PSA zusammen. Bei Essen will er übrigens auch. Das ist auch die Erklärung für den Deal. Die haben halt noch ein bisschen was auf der hohen Kante, was sie sich haben leisten können. Dafür kriegst du aber niemanden, der ernsthaft hilft. Also machen sie perspektivisch. Die haben ja auch in den Laien derart rumgebaut, um einfach links und rechts 2,50 Mark zu sparen, ohne dass sie davon überzeugt sind. Und Harvey Elliott ist ja wahrscheinlich so das größte Opfer von… Auch das verstehe ich by the way nicht, warum Liverpool die Laie nicht terminiert, weil der spielt nicht, weil es ansonsten eine Kaufverpflichtung gibt. Also die dosieren die Minuten sehr genau, weil sie sich den gar nicht leisten können. Und jetzt ist der da im Kader, trainiert mit, spielt aber nie, ist manchmal im Spieltags-Kader, damit er nicht komplett unzufrieden ist. Und Liverpool hat es einfach vergessen, die Laie zu terminieren. Aber ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, was da dahinter steckt. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Lieber spielt er bei Liverpool nicht und trainiert aber da, als dass man ihn bei Esten Willa einfach versauern lässt. Also diese Winterperiode, so gut die Sommerperiode war von Liverpool, die checke ich nicht. Gar nicht.
Ja, und dann haben wir ja noch ein Bonusthema.
Genau, kurz das Bonusthema. Nur einmal, wir müssen natürlich einmal nach Straßburg gucken, denn da haben wir ja über Absurditäten im Multiclub Ownership schon in der letzten Folge auch gesprochen. Und Überraschung, Überraschung, sie haben jetzt zwei Ligen terminiert von Chelsea mit Kendry Paez, der tatsächlich auch keine Rolle gespielt hat. Aber auch Mamadou Sarr ist zurück zu Chelsea. Der, man muss es sagen, der zweite Kapitän bei Straßburg auch war. Also hinter Emega, der ja auch keine Rolle mehr spielt und ja auch im Sommer zu Chelsea geht. Und da ist jetzt also das nächste riesige Stück aus der Straßburg-Mannschaft rausgerissen worden. Aber dafür haben sie auch Aaron Anselmino gekriegt, den Chelsea ja unbedingt wieder brauchte, angeblich von Dortmund.
War ein sehr wichtiges Spiel damals. Ja, ein sehr wichtiges Spiel damals.
Da aufgeschlagen ist und dann haben sie auch noch David Dattrow-Fofana geholt, der jetzt glaube ich in den letzten fünf, sechs Transferperioden zum fünften Mal an einen unterschiedlichen Verein verdienen wird von Chelsea. Also auch, der war ja auch mal bei Union, meine ich. Und ja, wird auch hin und her geschoben wie Ware und dann aber, um auf einen positiven Punkt zu enden, es gibt auch ein paar Transfers, die durchaus spannend sind und das sind jetzt Zugänge, denn da spreche ich vielleicht nicht unbedingt um Buna Saar, der zu Mest gegangen ist von den Bayern, aber zum einen natürlich Giro Immobile, immer noch ein cooler Name, der jetzt bei Paris FC spielt in der Rückrunde, auch gestern im Pokal sein Debüt gefeiert hat, da er auch schon eine gute Chance hatte, die er aber vergeben hat. Ich bin gespannt, jetzt bei Bologna hat er ja nicht unbedingt Bäume ausgerissen, aber vielleicht ist er so ein bisschen der Spieler, der bei Paris auch fehlt, denn die Zulieferung ist eigentlich ganz gut, finde ich, und da fehlte jemand auf der Stürmerposition. Dann Eli Wahi, der ja von Frankfurt ausgeliehen ist, ist richtig gut gestartet, hat drei Tore in vier Spielen gemacht bei Nizza.
Das sehen es GD-Fans auch gern.
Genau, da einen richtig guten Effekt gehabt. Dann hat man mit Rémi Cabella und Gaëtan Perrin noch zwei Urgesteine der Liga, die jetzt zurückgekommen sind. Perrin hat bei Auxerre in der letzten Saison auch 20 Scorer gesammelt, ist jetzt bei Lille. Cabella ist bei Nantes, die ja krass abstiegsgefährdet sind. Der war früher auch bei Montpellier, Marseille, Saint-Etienne, Lille, zwischendurch auch mal in Newcastle. Und dann aber mein persönlicher Favorite ist Alain Saint-Maximin, der bei Lens aufgeschlagen hat. Der war ja nicht so glücklich in Mexiko, soll da ja auch rassistisch beleidigt worden sein und so. Und der ist erst 28, da war ich echt ein bisschen überrascht. Und bei Lens hat man ja auch gute Erfahrungen gemacht, jetzt im Sommer mit Rückkehrern. Also Thauvin hat ja wahnsinnig gut eingeschlagen, ist einer der besten Spieler der Liga. Auch Odson Edouard funktioniert richtig gut. Und ich freue mich total, es am Maximale jetzt bei Lens zu sehen. Er hat gestern sein Debüt gefeiert im Pokal nach Einwechslung. Und da freue ich mich echt drauf. Denn wenn man sich an seine gute Newcastle-Zeit erinnert, kann das schon jetzt nochmal ein echter Unterschiedsspieler sein für Lens.
Gut nennst du die, okay.
Teilweise schon, oder?
Nein, das ist einfach der hetozentrische Spieler der Premier League-Geschichte, aber das war nicht schlecht.
Nur mal ganz kurz, um es reinzuwerfen. Seit seiner Newcastle-Zeit zu 23, Al-Hali, Fenerbahce, Mexiko mit CF America. So kann eine Fußballer-Karriere auch weitergehen. Wo hat das alles gelernt? Bei Hannover 96. Ja, so schaut es nämlich aus. Grüße an Ansgar, falls er das hier hört. Okay, also Ligue 1 war wild in diesem Wintertransfer-Fenster. Kann man, glaube ich, so zusammenfassen. Wild war auch so einiges, was Real mal wieder geliefert hat. Alex, wir haben ja die großen Probleme bei Real in der letzten Sendung schon besprochen. Aber jetzt gab es auch quasi in jüngerer Vergangenheit wieder Berichtenswerte. Was ist los bei Madrid?
Ja, ich würde gerne auch über Transfers hier sprechen, aber in La Liga wird ja nichts gekauft. Da hat ja keiner Geld außer Atletico. Wir hatten es ja. Von daher müssen wir sportlich werden, weil bei Real Madrid ja ein Aufreger-Spiel war. Also es war wirklich das Aufreger-Spiel dieses Spieltags und einer der Kontroversen, vielleicht sogar wirklich mit Blick auf die komplette Liga-Saison, wie, in welcher Art und Weise Real Madrid da sein Spiel wieder gewonnen hat. La Liga-Kenner sagen, naja, alles wie immer, alles wie gewohnt. Aber poch, also man musste schon mit dem armen Rallo, das ja alles gegeben hat, das ein sehr gutes Spiel gemacht hat, gegen ein Real, das bodenlos aussah. Also man muss es wirklich so ansprechen. Die spielen nicht wie eine Mannschaft Fußball, die spielen auch nicht wie ein Titel-Anwärter-Fußball, sondern das ist zusammenhanglos, das ist teilweise Larifari. Und das kleine RAIO, St. Pauli Spanien, hat im Bernabéu wirklich guten Fußball gespielt. Dann gab es eine rote Karte, eine berechtigte rote gewesen, muss man sagen, hier schön gestempelt, Stollen voraus, also keine Schiri-Kontroverse in dem Punkt. Aber dann ging es natürlich bergab für RAIO, mit 10 Mann logischerweise. Dann kam die Schlussphase von Real Madrid, hier Powerplay. Man kennt es ja aus der Champions League vor zwei Jahren gegen die PSG, Suncities dieser Welt. Das gründen sie auch sehr, sehr gut. Aber was sie halt dann machen, sie ziehen halt alle Register, um irgendwie ihr Tor zu schießen. Und meistens in der Saison ist ihr Tor halt der Elfmeter. Wir hatten vorhin eine Statistik bei irgendeinem Spieler, ich habe vergessen, wie er hieß. Die Hälfte der Tore bei Elfmeter, das kann man bei Mbappé, glaube ich, so auch nachlesen. Und ja, das Geschmäckle war eben, sie haben alles probiert, um irgendwie ihren Elfmeter zu bekommen. Und wenn man das gesehen hat, da muss man echt sagen, das war, poch, shameless Wahnsinn. Vier Schwalben nur in der zweiten Halbzeit, und man muss es Schwalben nennen, Flops, Schwalben, hinschmeißen, sobald ein Gegend in deiner Nähe ist und dich berühren könnte, schmeißen sie sich hin und sie bekommen halt nie eine gelbe Karte dafür und deswegen machen sie es immer weiter. Also es ist tatsächlich systematisches Schinden von Elfmetern, Vinicius einmal, zweimal Mbappé selbst, mit einem, mit einer Schraube, wo du, Alter, also wenn du das siehst, Brahim Dias hat es einmal probiert. Es gab nicht den Elfmeter, aber es gab auch nie eine gelbe, also machen sie es weiter. Und dann gab es neun Minuten Nachspielzeit, woher die kamen, weiß kein Mensch. Und dann gab es in der acht Minuten Nachspielzeit dann doch endlich den Elfmeter bei, auch einem. Den kannst du pfeifen, aber musst du ihm pfeifen, weiß ich nicht, weil der Ball auch berührt wird und natürlich macht Brahim wieder mehr draus. Also es war ein Spiel, über das ja in Spanien natürlich sehr, sehr enthusiastisch dann berichtet und gesprochen wurde im Nachhinein. Und Real Madrid hat mal wieder ein Spiel irgendwie gewonnen, aber ohne, dass sie wirklich überzeugen und eben mit Hilfe der verschiedenen Kräfte, die es so gibt, unter anderem der Anziehungskraft.
Und wenn wir jetzt Nils hier hätten vom Tiki Taka Podcast, der ja eher die Real-Sicht der Dinge vertritt, würde der das auch so darstellen?
Das kann man sehr schön in der Folge am Montag nachhören, übrigens Max, als wir darüber gesprochen haben. Und er hat auch gesagt, ja, die Schwalben, das ist schon too much des Guten oder der Schlechten in dem Fall. Also man weiß ja, in Spanien, da wird immer Schauspielerei begangen und Zeitspiel, das gehört dazu zur Kultur in Spanien, leider. Aber jetzt hat es Real Madrid wirklich, wirklich übertrieben. Also es waren allein vier Schwalben, systematisches Schinden. Und wenn das nicht bestraft wird, und das ist ja das Thema, das eigentlich oben drüber steht oder das eigentliche Kernthema, wenn du das nicht bestrafst und sanktionierst, was machst du denn? Du förderst es. Es führt dazu, dass Spieler, egal von welchem Verein, egal in welchem Spiel, sich natürlich erst recht hinschmeißen, schinden, Schauspielern sich das Gesicht halten, wenn sie an der Schulter getroffen werden, wenn sie irgendwo berührt werden, unten, es gibt einen Kontakt, schmeißen sich hin, wollen ihren Elfmeter. Das führt dir dazu, dass das immer mehr betrieben wird von egal welchen Spielern, weil du es nicht sanktionierst, weil du Schauspielerei nicht eindämmst. Das gab es auch im Baskendurby zwischen Real Sociedad und Athletic Bilbao, wo der eine Spieler den anderen etwas gegen die Schulter schubst, der andere sagt, geh weg, lass mich in Ruhe, berührt den hier irgendwo, und der schmeißt sich hin und hält sich natürlich das Gesicht, und der Spieler kriegt die rote Karte für nichts, ein absoluter Nichts. Nichts war das. Und er war, bleibt stumm. So, und das förderst du eben, Schauspielerei, Schwalben, Übertreiben, Schinden, weil du es nicht eindämmst, weil du es nicht sanktionierst durch gelbe Karten. Und das steht über allem. Und Real Madrid, dass die so natürlich dann zum Erfolg gekommen sind, und die haben es halt eben wirklich übertrieben, ist ja nicht nur geschmäckle, sondern wirklich sehr, sehr unschön gewesen.
Ich habe eine Frage noch an dich, Alex. Gibt's du inzwischen im Nürnberger Raum immer die Hand her nach den Spielen? Oder hat sich da nichts verbessert?
Okay, okay. Selbstverständlich mache ich das immer, weil mir wurde ja gesagt, ich muss das machen. Ja, gut.
Ja, dann können wir mal wissen, weil das klang schon wieder danach, als würdest du da persönliche Dinge in Richtung Schiedsrichter loswerden wollen.
Also es gab in letzter Zeit tatsächlich keinen Grund, einen Handschlag zu verweigern oder dem aus… also nicht verweigern.
Also hast du oft genug gewonnen in der Vergangenheit.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wurde selten genug beschissen von den Schiedsrichtern. Nee, es gab eigentlich keine Vorkommnisse jeglicher negativer Art. Aber meine Spieler schinden auch zu wenig Elfmeter. Vielleicht sollte ich ihnen auch das beibringen. für mir selbst.
Alex, aufhören jetzt. Wir wollen nicht wieder… also an alle diejenigen, die das jetzt nicht verstanden haben, ihr hört zu wenig Ligatour, da habt ihr ein legendäres Segment verpasst. Ist schon ein paar Wochen her oder ein paar Monate. Sogar schon, aber ja.
Lass es hier bald gewinnen.
Ich glaube, wir können froh sein, wenn Alex dem lokalen Schiedsrichter-Chef nicht anfängt, Geld zu zahlen, oder?
Oh, okay, okay.
Die Black Knight Football Group, die würden da im Verein einsteigen, weißt du Bescheid.
Aber wirklich, ich würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn irgendwo ein Papagei im Hintergrund auftaucht und der eine Hass-Terade auf Real Madrid anfängt zu singen. Oder ich weiß nicht, wer jetzt eure direkten Konkurrenten bei euch im Nürnberger Raum sind. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich…
Für zu weit.
Schiedsrichter.
Vestenbachs-Gebäude.
Genau. Für zu weit. Also ich merke schon, das Schiedsrichter-Thema mache ich so schnell hier nicht mehr auf, wenn Uli zu kass ist.
Das fühlt sich nicht so gut an.
Du warst einfach einmal zu ehrlich, Alex. Und das wird halt einfach bestraft. Das könnte Real Madrid halt nicht passieren.
Das stimmt.
Oh, das gibt die. Viel Spaß.
Ja, ach, lustigerweise hören die entsprechenden Bubbles, hören die Ligatour nicht. Also deswegen, hier kannst du auch einfach sagen, ja, Leo Messi ist halt klar besser als Cristiano Ronaldo. Haut alle ab, ihr Pfeifen.
Und das an seinem Geburtstag.
Und das wird nicht passieren. Wer ist es, Leo Messi oder Cristiano Ronaldo? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hoffe, das stimmt. Ich habe das gerade nur beim Überfliegen gesehen, dass der heute 41 war.
Das wäre jetzt wirklich schlimm, wenn wir eben… Na gut.
Na gut. Dann verlassen wir es dabei.
Ein Punkt, kurz überlegt, ob ich nochmal nachlege.
Aber ich glaube, das war genug Zunder für diese Folge. Wir haben noch ein Thema in der Serie A offen. Christian, was hast du uns mitgebratzt? Muss jetzt unterhaltsam sein? Ja, vielleicht wird es unterhaltsam, hoffentlich. Ja, schauen wir uns kurz mal Udinese an von Kosta Runjaic, die wirklich sehr, sehr gut dastehen. Gerade auch aktuell haben die Roma geschlagen. Jetzt an diesem Spieltag 1 zu 0. Sie haben gleich viele Punkte wie Lazio. Sie sind Punkt gleich 8 oder 9. Auch nur wenige Punkte von Atalanta weg. Also wenn wir uns ja erinnern, vielleicht die letzten Jahre, da war Udinese auch immer wieder dann Richtung Abstiegsstrudeln mit dabei. Und das Thema ist jetzt schon durch. Die haben, glaube ich, was sagen sie, 15 Punkte vorsprungen und haben wirklich nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun. Also wieder sehr, sehr solide. Im Prinzip macht Udinese weiterhin das, was sie in den Jahren davor schon gemacht haben, in dem sie eben sehr solide und gut waren. Weiterhin eine extrem körperlich starke Mannschaft. Also Gasperini hat es jetzt eben auch. Ich meine, die Roma ist jetzt auch nicht unkörperlich. Aber er hat gemeint, Udinese hat uns einfach im physischen Bereich, waren sie uns überlegen. Also das ist weiter das Grundmotiv, dass sie fahren. Picken wir uns zwei, drei Spieler raus, glaube ich, weil man Udinese ja nicht immer auf dem Schirm hat. Das Siegtor gerade gegen die Roma hat Jürgen Ekelenkamp geschossen. Vielleicht erinnert sich noch ein paar. Hertha BSC-Vergangenheit, das ist einer, der da gut funktioniert. Vielleicht der größte Name vom Namen her. Sie haben Niccolò Zaniolo zurückgeholt von Galatasaray. Zaniolo ist in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen rumgegeistert, irgendwo nie wieder das Niveau gefunden, dass er da in jungen Jahren bei der Roma hatte. Auch klar hat man ja auch schon, gibt es außerfußballerische Themen, aber auch zwei Kreuzbandrisse. Also muss man auch mit drin halten. Aber jetzt scheint er, er kam von Galatasaray und scheint bei Udinese wirklich den Rhythmus gefunden haben. Mehrere Tore schon, ganz entscheidend. Jetzt einen kleinen Eingriff am Knie gehabt, aber anscheinend nichts Schlimmeres. Ich glaube, ich kann in zwei, drei Wochen schon wieder mit dabei sein. Also Zaniolo funktioniert richtig gut, für ihn logisch sehr gut und auch für Udinese. Keenan Davis, mal schauen, ob der Uli noch was sagt. Ich glaube, von Aston Villa kam der vor zwei oder drei Jahren. Also physisch sehr physisch starker Neuner, funktioniert richtig gut, trifft. Da gab es zuletzt auch mehrere Transfergerüchte, da waren auch größere dran. Hatte so ein bisschen nur, um eine Idee zu bekommen, was das für ein Spielertyp ist, hat jetzt so ein, zwei Mal einen Lukaku-Stempel bekommen. Also wirklich einer, der physisch einfach wahnsinnig viel mitbringt und eben da perfekt da vorne mit reinpasst. Und damit wir einen Jakob auch mit reinholen, Arthur Atta, ex Mets, den hat Udinese von Mets geholt. Der war früher, glaube ich, auch so im Umfeld der französischen UN-Nationalmannschaften, 23. Der macht wirklich den nächsten Schritt. Der war letztes Jahr schon sehr vielversprechend, ist jetzt auch, hat schon mehrere Tore geschossen und sehr auffällig einfach einer. Und damit sind wir wieder beim Punkt. Bei Udinese kommt es jetzt anscheinend wieder in die Richtung. Das war ja das Udinese von früher, sehr gutes Scouting, immer wieder mal Leute holen, die anderen noch nicht auf dem Schirm haben, dann später logischerweise damit Geld verdienen. Habe jetzt auch mir ein bisschen angeschaut, das ist wirklich faszinierend. Also das Scouting scheint wieder zu greifen. Udinese hat zum Beispiel auch den Kapitän, bitte leg mich nicht auf den Namen fest, den Kapitän der französischen U19-Nationalmannschaften. Zwei Achterjahrgang. Also auch solche ganz junge Leute, die sind einfach schon da, die holen sie, haben jetzt auch im Winter ganz interessante jungen serbischen Innenverteidiger geholt. Den wollte der Inter, den wollten viele in Europa. Aber er kam dann zu Dinesse, weil er da jetzt wahrscheinlich Spielpraxis kriegt. Also, dass Dinesse Scout den greift wieder. Und dementsprechend macht da Rounia Hatsch logisch einen sehr, sehr guten Job. Sehr schön Max, danke, dass du das noch kurz aufmachst. Und das alles vor dem Hintergrund, um auch nochmal die Brücke zu Jakob zu schlagen, dass sie im Sommer nicht nur Thauvin abgegeben haben, sondern auch Lorenzo Lucca. Also der neun oder letzte Saison, der ja wirklich sehr wichtig war. Also im Prinzip haben sie ja ein komplettes Sturmbuhr, das sie offensiv getragen hat, abgegeben. Sind jetzt aber besser.
Hab ich dich zu dem noch was fragen, zu Lucca? Weil der ist ja in Nottingham. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich machen soll mit dem.
Da bist du nicht allein, Uli. Also, Lucca noch ganz kurz. Er hat letztes Jahr gut funktioniert, junger Mann. Den hat er Napoli geholt für viel Geld. Da reden wir, glaube ich, hoch 20 oder über 30. Und bei Napoli und Conte, das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Also wir kennen ja die Geschichte von Napoli, die ungefähr alle Krankenhäuser in und um Neapel mit Spielern belegen. Also in Neapel, wenn du diese Saison mal Spielzeit hättest kriegen können, dann jetzt. Und obwohl sie so viele Verletzte hatten, hat Lucca und der Conte zuletzt sogar gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt. Also das wurde gar nichts. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch ein paar Szenen auch in der Champions League. Da waren ein paar technische Fehler auch mit dabei, wo du sagst, ich weiß nicht. Also der hat sicher den Schritt, glaube ich, der war groß. Ich meine, wenn du von Udine, wo du halt in einem kleinen Biotop bist, wo dir auch medial nicht viel passieren kannst, wenn du dann als Junge nach Neapel kommst zum Meister, große Aufmerksamkeit, viel Geld für dich bezahlt. Der Schritt war, glaube ich, zu groß, kann man jetzt sagen. Deswegen überrascht es mich auch, dass der in der Premier League jetzt einen Abnehmer gefunden hat. Überraschung, weißt du Uli, logisch, er bringt halt eine Physis mit. Das ist logischerweise, davon lebt er. Aber ganz schwierig, ich weiß nicht. Bin sehr gespannt, wie viel er jetzt da spielt. Weil wie gesagt, Conte hat den wirklich nicht mehr gesehen. Conte hat teilweise 17-jährige Nachwuchsspieler vor ihnen in der Schlussphase gebracht, wenn sie in Rückstand waren. Und er war fit. Also, ja, deswegen, das, glaube ich, wird jetzt auch erst mal die nächsten Wochen noch ein Mysterium sein, bin ich mal gespannt. Aber bei dem ist viel im Kopf. Der Schritt nach Neapel, glaube ich, war zu groß für ihn, genau. Und ist das für dich ein Thema, dass wir mit Kosta Runjaic, ja, da auch einen uns bekannten Trainer, deswegen wollte ich sie auch mal mitbringen, ja. Also, für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, Darmstadt Duisburg, Lautern 60 und dann eben über Auslandsstationen in Stettin und Warschau dann eben bei Udinese gelandet. Ja, also, wie gesagt, ist er einer, der auch in Italien logisch jetzt nicht groß im Fokus steht. Vielleicht zur Erinnerung nochmal, vor ihm war Fabio Cannavaro Trainer bei Udinese. Also, da haben sie so den großen Namen halt gesucht und dann kam eben Ronjaic. Und ja, ich glaube, alle, die Ronjaic auch aus Deutschland kennen, ist glaube ich jetzt nicht unbedingt einer, der groß im Mittelpunkt steht oder auch das Scheinwerferlicht auf sich zieht. Aber wenn man jetzt die Saison eben anschaut, das ist halt schon stark. Wenn du mit Lazio mitspielst, wenn du nur wenige Punkte dahinter Atalanta bist und eigentlich vom Prinzip her sogar ein bisschen nach oben Richtung europäische Plätze schiedeln kannst und im Sommer Thauvin und Luka verloren hast, dann würde ich sagen, spricht das sehr für die ruhige Art von Ronjaic. Wie gesagt, auch in Italien nicht groß auf dem Radar, aber macht seinen Job und führt eben genau diesen Weg fort. Körperlich unangenehm, stark, physisch. Und hat zuletzt eben nicht nur die Roma, hat auch Napoli geschlagen. Also ja, definitiv eine richtig, richtig gute Saison von Uli Nese und von Ronjaic. So, und Jakob hat die letzte Frage dieser Sendung.
Ich wollte nur kurz den Namen nachtragen des französischen Nationalmannschaftskapitäns. Das ist Abdullai Kamara.
Ja, danke.
Der kam der letzten Sommer aus Montpellier. 1,2 Millionen für den Kapitän von der französischen UNationalmannschaft. Das ist schon ein ganz netter Deal auf jeden Fall.
Würde ich auch mal sagen, genau, auf dem Papier erst mal. Jetzt schauen wir mal als ein junger Mann, wie sich das entwickelt. Aber das eben nur als Beispiel, dass eben genau das Kernstück von Dinesse, das die ja seit über, kann man sagen, ein, zwei Jahrzehnte stark gemacht hat. Da könnte man jetzt ein ganzes Thema aufmachen, wer alles durch die Dinesse-Schule gegangen ist. Und das war vielleicht die letzten ein, zwei Jahre, ist da so ein bisschen Knick reingekommen. Und jetzt scheint es wieder auf einem guten Weg zu sein, dass sie da wirklich auch dieses Scouting, dass es wieder greift. Und so schnell kann es gehen. Vorhin sag ich noch, französische Liga, französischer Markt komplett überkauft und begründet das mit irgendwelchen 30-Millionen-Transfers von 17-Jährigen nach Saudi-Arabien. Und jetzt sehen wir, na ganz so schlimm überkauft kann er ja noch nicht sein, wenn du die Kamera noch holen kannst. Naja, so schnell geht es auch im Rasenfunk. Ihr vier, das war wie immer eine sehr, sehr schöne Sendung. Danke, dass ihr euch auch die Zeit dafür genommen habt. Wurde ja heute etwas länger. Herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel, Alex Truica, Jakob Haffke und Christian Bernhard. Vielen, vielen Dank euch allen. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, ihr habt diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbungsponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Paul, bei Sebastian, Sebi Kreisig, bei Lothar, bei Sebastian und bei QQ-Joba. Vielen Dank für euren Support. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann geht sehr gerne auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Da könnt ihr es loswerden. Und empfehlt doch diese Sendung sehr, sehr gerne weiter. Jetzt nicht unbedingt an Cristiano Ronaldo Fanboys. Das braucht dann doch nicht. Aber allen anderen sei diese Folge hier sehr ans Herz gelegt. In diesem Sinne, bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.